okay i would like to nominate my
favorite spider-man villain as spell
check
yeah
and can we all agree that the first
draft of this character was known as
grammar nazi like maybe
there's no way he wasn't right there's
no way he wasn't tom excuse me i hate to
correct you but the first draft of this
character was the paper clip from
microsoft word that yells at you oh
clippy oh clippy
clippy was the first draft of spell
check
oh my gosh
nina
who is your pick for dumbest spider-man
villain of all time
thanks brian um so i did some a little
research today
tom's not not doing well i don't think
i'm doing great i'm doing first all
right um and i'm sure that you two will
chime in because i'm talking to two bona
fide comic experts but i found a really
dumb villain on our list at looper.com
and i found a favorite fact about him
but the gist is his name is typeface um
and he first appeared in peter parker
spiderman volume
volume 2 number 23 in 2000.
and actually a comic book i bought off
the rack
nice i remember buying um actually i
lied i have two facts that i love about
typeface but then i'm curious like about
more stuff about typeface so basically
he puts letters on his face and he also
uses letters to kill people am i correct
in this
yeah well he uses letters to beat people
up right but he puts an r
or
um
an a on his face and the r is for
retribution and the a's for annihilation
and i'm like those are the only words
yeah um
but i found two really great facts about
him that i'm obsessed with can i pause
right here before before you tell us the
fact
yeah wouldn't have been a cooler villain
if he just put an r on his forehead and
called himself retribution and got rid
of the rest of the stuff yeah none of
the rest of the stuff is necessary like
it's just like letters just for you just
used regular knives i don't want to say
why because you might be about to tell
us that right well he feels like well he
feels like that villain in the first
austin powers movie who throws a shoe
and he's just like who throws a [ __ ]
thank you random task okay so the first
fact that i loved is you know after
uh he's
after they try to explode him and he
doesn't die um
he
he becomes a vigilante and he inspires
another vigilante who names himself
spell check yeah i checked that
that sucks that's the worst thing i've
ever heard i hate it so much
somebody buried the lead pretty hard on
this let's talk spell check what spell
checks deal
i'm sharing the picture in our chat
right now
oh boy no way
[Laughter]
this guy rocks oh wait with great power
there must also come great vocabulary
that is money right there oh man
every editor in the world just screamed
so spell check spell check shows up in
one issue of tangled web of spider-man
which is sort of that makes sense there
it is so tom tom knows this as the comic
book
that's about spider-man's like tertiary
it's like hey spider-man's cool what
about stuff that happens around
spider-man when he's not there so that's
kind of what's going on here it was
almost it was like so basically they
were like do you like spiderman
they were like do you love spiderman but
you want less spiderman
that's 100 what it was
it was like it was this bizarre like
creative writing class sort of
playground for writers where they got to
do it they did like a flowers for
algernon story where uh where the rhino
got really smart for
two issues and then realized that it's a
lot easier to be a dumb villain
sure
so in this in this comic book that i
checked out before our chat because i
saw that fact too i was cuz i remembered
typeface from a million years ago when i
got the comic and then i saw oh and he
inspired a vigilante named spell check i
was like shut up and so i looked at it
and it's just this one issue with a very
stylized art style so that's why this in
this picture he looks like a zombie
right he's meant to just be a normal man
um but his whole deal his the only way
that he's a vigilante is that he's just
like out to get people who use bad
grammar okay i would like to nominate my
favorite spider-man villain as spell
check
yeah
and can we all agree that the first
draft of this character was known as
grammar nazi like
maybe there's no way he wasn't right
there's no way he wasn't tom excuse me i
hate to correct you but the first draft
of this character was the paper clip
from microsoft word that yells at you oh
clippy oh clippy
clippy was the first draft of spell
check oh yeah oh my gosh
i'd like to see a team up
oh man
it looks like you know
i bet he you know murdered people when
they
screwed up sneak peek p-e-k versus sneak
peek p-e-a-k which is
a thing people do
basically all he did in this in this one
issue that he appeared in is that he
chased typeface down he's like oh i can
help you and then typeface is like
you're too weird for me this is a man
who's covered in letters and beating
people up with letters and he's like get
out of here you freak freaky and then at
the end he beats up spell check and
hangs him from a light post like
spider-man and leaves a note saying from
your friendly neighborhood type face and
spider-man finds it and he's like well
that's weird he just uses the same
catchphrase and just puts his name into
it he doesn't even come up with anything
more interesting that's the joke that
they were doing it's fine it's one of
those it's one of those strange things
but yeah so typeface i was reading that
comic book that typeface first shows up
in and i was just i think that was the
comic the issue that made me like not
interested in that comic book anymore
because i was just like
am i supposed to take this guy seriously
because he seems like he's being
depicted as very deadly and as a
formidable foe for spider-man like he
beats up and knocks out spider-man like
in their first encounter but like he's
just some clown who's covered himself in
letters and has
knives that look like letters
i think
i don't know he just sucks he's so the
reason that he's typeface is because he
used to be a a sign painter
right that's his big origin story he had
a sign so he came back from vietnam and
i guess his wife left him and his
brother died and he started a sign
painting business and then someone
bought his sign painting business and i
guess fired him and he got really mad
about it and now he's a villain
and he needed some of that r for
retribution i'll tell you what uh
surprises me the most about the story
brian is that you own the first
appearance of typeface and you've chosen
to just keep working for a living when
you could have sold that
oh no i'm sure i sold that many years
ago for a nickel
that's gone that's gone i used this to
work
i used to work at that comic shop and
every so often i would i would haul in
my old comics and be like i don't need
these anymore i'm in college and they'd
give me some comic book credit and on i
would go and that that that issue has
been gone for
literal decades so ryan can i ask you a
question about something else i found
about typeface you can try i won't
promise i'll know an answer but give me
so
a fact that i found
fact i don't know if it's true because
it's i saw it on wikipedia and i tried
to trace it to the source and it's gone
but apparently paul jenkins who is one
of the writers of of the of this comic
said that if and when
typeface dies
the only guarantee we have is his eyes
will turn into little x's
that's cute and i was just like it's
appalling that you have to tell us that
i mean it's cute that he said like was
anyone laying awake at night being like
but will his eyes turn into exes like i
i'm sure they asked him that
i'm sure that was that probably came up
in the same way where it's like hey we
got to interview paul jenkins the
creator of the century the writer of the
influential inhumans comic and they're
like so let me ask you about this
villain you made typeface and he's like
oh man
i mean i had to i had to write something
that day his publicist is like no more
typeface questions
i'm sure it's the same thing where like
when they ask the people who wrote the
best episode of star trek ever threshold
whenever they talk to them about that
episode the one where tom paris turned
into a lizard and abducted captain
janeway and turned her into a lizard and
then they both had lizard babies
i'm sure it's the same kind of thing
where it's like you've had a great
career working in star trek let me ask
you about this one horribly embarrassing
thing you have to own it so sure george
clooney always gets asked about batman
and robin always he's still talking
about it yeah george clooney has had
such a great career and if anyone gives
him guff over batman they're just like
like you're missing the point man yeah
it's yeah combined 36 oceans i mean the
guy has done good work
no but he's like the last old hollywood
figure we have and everybody's like so
what about the nipples on the batman
suit like still you're still asking
about it
there are a lot of villains on this list
here that i like over on looper.com
we've got the spider queen who was
actually in a storyline i really like
which was spider island where all the
all the residents of new york get turned
into spiders
spider people and she's like the
mastermind controlling everyone
i was i was tempted by spider queen
because our article says she can kill by
screaming and i was like that's funny
she has a screamy kill there's also a
lot of characters on here i just don't
know like i i've read a lot of
spider-man i i've never heard of banjo
oh banjo come on i've never heard a band
one appearance
one issue of one comic back in the 80s i
don't know
manslaughter marsdale
i don't know sticks and stone
but i do know
i'll mention you know what i won't
mention some of the ones i do know
because tom you picked from this list
too didn't you i i did i did grab one
from this list why don't why don't we
why don't we flip to you for now let's
let's uh
who did you pick from this list so i
don't like start talking about someone
that you picked
oh i i feel like i promise that you
won't there's basically nothing to say
but i wish it had been banjo banjo's i
mean
gracious i just think whenever i hear
banjo i think about space ghost
lamenting his dead aunt
do you know that one that he just
follows around for the whole episode
banjo
tom tell us who you picked tell us tell
us tell us
tell us something stop me from talking
please okay so i i i went back to this
one because
it's not because this is a fascinating
character but it is because it's sort of
representative of a lot of the stuff
that drives me crazy about comics um
i was a kid in in the in the 90s and i
remember you know not really getting to
buy a lot of comics but definitely
seeing them on the shelf and
you would see a character and it would
catch your eye catch your attention
you'd be like man i wonder what his deal
is and then you'd have to wait until you
were an adult to actually find out what
the hell was going on with this dude and
generally speaking by the time you that
there was like a wikipedia page
dedicated to some trash can character
it was 20 years later and you it
you would look it up and you get you'd
feel that rush of excitement that you
got when you were a kid
and then realized that this was just
trash that this was just like
tail end of the 80s a little bit too
much cocaine still in the system
and like
there was not a lot of great stuff so uh
1992 it's it's the golden age of sort of
todd mcfarlane uh
let's toss too many teeth on something
and make it scary uh aesthetic
so like venom had come out i think uh
four years earlier earlier the same year
carnage had showed up
uh and then marvel introduces this new
character called the doppelganger
who's uh
uh
very much in the same vein as venomous
carnage in that it's it's just a
scarier-looking version of spider-man
uh
only with the the added details that
there's basically nothing to him he's
he's uh
he's spider-man but with six arms
so you got the whole like eight i was
just about to ask how similar he was to
toby maguire's goth spider-man and
spider-man 3.
very different
that would have
similar dancing but that's where the
similarities oh okay we can get anybody
to animate like
you just nominated yourself tom yeah
we can get you to animate whatever
you're talking about yeah yeah
so it's it's spider-man it's like the
spider-man costume and everything but on
a on an eight-limbed creature with uh
with scary scratchy fingies and uh a
great big
and great great big bitey teeth he's got
the faggotties if you want to try and go
into the back story it's exhausting it's
not fun
he's a spider clone right
nope
no okay i'm sorry no you would think so
no this was the right time for that sort
of
stuff uh no this would
it doesn't matter uh character called
the magus who's like a a different
version of adam warlock like an evil
adam warlock uses the technology of
another character named anthropomorpho
god i hate the 90s and uh and
uses it to make evil versions of all of
these marvel characters
and that's it you just you wind up with
just panels and panels of like captain
america but he's got scary sharp teeth
and red eyes and a buzz saw instead of a
shield and alpha flight
except they've all got
red eyes and scary sharp teeth they it
morally almost all of them were just
people
the way that you were used to seeing
them but with red eyes
and scary sharp teeth and spider-man got
one of them and uh he died immediately
didn't have a personality didn't he was
just like a scarier spider-man
too and then yeah
beautiful if you're to stay dead because
they brought him back
and some totally he's done nothing the
last
close to 30 years that he's been around
he's done practically nothing he shows
up every once in a while and he's scary
i remember a friend of mine had the
action figure so obviously he stuck out
in my mind but aside from that yeah he's
just like he's cool i'll say this he
looks cool in that 90s sort of way if
you are
you know 13 and reading comic books
totally yeah like visually
but did you think about it for five
seconds and you're like no yeah not so
good and couldn't come up with a better
name than doppelganger for a spider
thief an evil spider right you know
right and aren't there like a lot of
poisonous spiders out there in the world
yeah a lot of them mm-hmm
but
at the same time
the fact that he he just keeps showing
up and that he's basically an animal
he's like he's this nasty like
he he's barely sentient if at all
that means that like somebody somebody
is special ordering costumes for him
because he's always in the spiderman
outfit
a six-armed spider-man outfit a
six-armed spider-man outfit which is
person is yeah why am i all delivering
all of these spiderman costumes
we've got a pretty good idea where
doppelganger's gonna show up
yeah and he's got prime shipping
[Laughter]
that's my pick i yeah no really
although it he could have been stood in
for by like any of the 90s like too
scary too many fangs characters there's
a lot we're up to like 90 symbiotes now
it's
it's exhausting right but which one did
you pick man well speaking of the 90s i
just want to run through a few more of
the ones on this list here we've got the
jackal on our list who
i understand why he's here he probably
didn't start out quite so bad but he
just became like this pain in the ass
where he's like i've cloned you
spider-man and he's like oh i got to
deal with this clone and then he's like
guess what i cloned the clones
spider-man i did it again
right and then he's like i cloned myself
spider-man uh would you like to see my
favorite
thing that uh that the jack will ever
created my favorite creation of his yes
please
uh
do you remember flir uh
trading cards from back in the day
sure
now see that guy right there
his name's shockle ganger it's nuts
shockle gangers my i mean i pro i wish
that they called them that man no it's
doppel shock it is double shock shocker
is funnier they're both good thank you
they're both good
for the trading cards they made a uh
they made a jackal clone thing that he
had created that was a combination of
the doppelganger and the shocker
which
gives me the opportunity to say doppels
shocker at work and that's uh
that's my contribution to
today's conversation
and he's like all about cloning which is
not really something that like jackals
have a lot to do with so he's awful he's
just gonna ask for starters he's a
psychopath he's like i'm a jackal
i've never heard his storyline put in
such succinct terms and that is the
funniest
that i love now all of a sudden i love
this character
i did it again spider-man and one of
them speaking of again here's another me
i love this this is great one of one of
his clones is also on our list and his
name is spider-side because he kills all
the spider clones so he sucks
oh like oh like homicide i thought yeah
s-i-d-e yeah totally get where you're
coming from but my pick is actually none
of these items on the list i picked one
i went off off menu for this one
um it's a character that's been brought
up by a podcast duo that i really like
the the mr sunday movies uh weekly
planet guys james and mason they
mentioned this spider-man bad guy a lot
and i like him for the reason that he is
very dumb and if you look up any
where ours is the only list that doesn't
have seem to list this guy which we
should probably rectify immediately uh
it's a villain named big
wheel tom are you familiar with big
wheel i know big wheel big wheel in the
rocket racer they go hand in hand baby
that's right so
so the story of big wheel is that
there's this guy jackson wheel w-e-l-e
that's his name that's his name his name
is wheel jackson wheel and he hires this
this villain rocket racer who has a
superpower jet skateboard and he
rides around new york city doing crimes
he hires him to get these incriminating
documents does he do anything
jackson wheel is a businessman and he no
i'm just so irritated that his name is
wheel
that's what they do like um well but
wait no it actually ties into a story
it's a hangout
it gets better no no no no wait it gets
better so he hires rocket racer to hire
to to get these documents and he does
and then he's like wait you don't have
the most incriminating document here and
rocket racers like i know i'm going to
blackmail you now
gotcha
and so jackson wheel is like oh
you got me
so i'm so mad i could build a big wheel
well so what happens is when when when
rocket racer is taunting jackson wheel
he's like i got you now
yeah big wheel like big wheel he's like
cause he's like a big business man he
calls him big wheel
any and then he and then so then jackson
wheel goes to the tinkerer who is the
super villain invention guy
he says i gotta get this rocket racer
i'm so mad when he's always calling me
big wheel
and the tigger goes
that gives me an idea
an hour to watch brian act out plots
so he gives him a giant
wheel
made of steel oh is it like a ferris
wheel or yeah
[Laughter]
nina you're not familiar with the
characters so let me help you out here
what you want to look for here is the
great big wheel
you see that
oh you know i didn't see it at first so
now now i do so thank you
and so and so he shows up
so spider-man and rocket racer are
fighting and all of a sudden this goon
shows up in a giant wheel and he starts
chasing rocket racers spider-man's like
i don't know what's going on and so
eventually
spider-man gets he starts fighting
rocket racer again on a rooftop and big
wheel goes up the building to get after
rocket racer and then they like move out
of the way and big wheel falls into the
hudson river
so there he is he's shown up a few more
times since then but he's always
basically a dope
um
yeah so that's no
i'm not sorry because now i know the big
wheel exists
big wheel
yeah and you know what it justifies my
fear of ferris wheels which was
originally due to heights and is now due
to crime
[Laughter]
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe bye
[Music]
you